hagamos algunos ejemplos más de
ecuaciones diferenciales exactas estos
problemas los estoy sacando de la página
80 de mi antiguo libro de ecuaciones
diferenciales que es la quinta edición
del libro de william boyce y richard y
prima sólo quiero hacer esto para
asegurarme de que reciban crédito por
estos problemas y bueno de todos modos
aquí solo voy a dar un montón de
ecuaciones diferenciales y vamos a
averiguar si estas son exactas o no ok
para después de averiguar sus soluciones
la primera de ellas vamos a ver vamos a
escribir 12 x + 32 x más tres más dos
menos dos y esto último vamos a
multiplicarlo por mi prima y lo
igualamos a cero así que esta función va
a ser nuestra m y esta de la derecha va
a ser nuestra n muy bien está m y está n
ahora se le puede decir a lo mejor a
primera vista quién es nuestra app si
antes de hacer todo el análisis pero
bueno vamos a ver quién es la parcial de
m respecto de iu pues es una función que
depende sólo de x por lo tanto
simplemente será 0 también del lado
derecho con nuestra función n vemos que
cuál es la tasa de cambio respecto de x
o su derivada respecto de x bueno es una
función que depende de ella por lo tanto
su derivada respecto de x simplemente
será 0 ok y de hecho me subí es igual a
nsv x porque ambas son 0 lo cual nos
dice según todo lo que ya hemos visto
que es una ecuación diferencial exacta
ok si ustedes lo ven hubieran visto tal
vez que en realidad esta es una ecuación
de variables separables pero bueno aquí
estamos ejercitando este tipo de
problemas y vamos a tratar de ver quién
es si entonces la derivada de sí
respecto de x es 2 x + 3 que es nuestra
función m
ok ahora la parcial de sí respecto de iu
pues es la n que en este caso es 2 - 2
ahora si podemos encontrar nuestra app
si sabemos que esto solo es el
la derivada total de epsy respecto de x
no
la derivada total de sí respecto de x
nos debe dar igual a 0 que no es otra
cosa más que si sube x más si subió
porque prima ok y así es como
encontramos la relación entre m y n y
las derivadas parciales de pepsi ok
concluimos como dije anteriormente que
la derivada total de epsy respecto de x
es igual a cero ahora déjenme cambiar
los colores para hacer esto más cómodo
esta ecuación diferencial es de la cual
queremos encontrar nuestra app si muy
bien entonces esto sólo puede ser
descrita como la derivada de epsy
respecto de x igual a cero utilizando la
regla de la cadena que son estas dos
líneas que tengo aquí a la derecha así
que esta derivada respecto de x
corresponde a m esta derivada respecto
de que corresponde a n y este es el
punto entero de las de las ecuaciones
exactas de todos modos vamos a averiguar
cuál es nuestra sí pero antes de hacerlo
vamos a ver esta expresión vamos a
integrar respecto d
y si tenemos que si debe ser igual
alguna constante y utilizando esta
información vamos a ver si podemos
resolver quienes si resolviendo si
entonces ya tendremos la solución de
esta ecuación diferencial dada por esta
relación a continuación si tenemos
algunas condiciones iniciales podremos
determinar quién es la constante c así
que vamos a integrar de estos de ambos
lados y luego vamos a ver qué pasa
entonces si es x cuadrada más 3x que es
la integral de este lado derecho y aquí
podemos agregar cualquier función que
dependa de ella sí porque es una
constante aquí hay que agregar una
constante pero para fines de integral
respecto de x pues cualquier función de
jeff puede ser una constante ok entonces
vamos a ver con qué continuamos por
ejemplo si tomamos la derivada parcial
de esto respecto de x pues esta
constante
o más bien esta función que depende de
ella pues se hace cero al derivarse
respecto de x por eso es que podemos
agregar cualquier función que dependa de
lleva ahora usemos esta información
tomamos la parcial respecto de y de esta
expresión y vamos a igualar con esta de
acá arriba de la derecha para ver cómo
tiene que ser esta función h
entonces la derivada parcial de eps y
respecto de ye pues simplemente va a ser
la derivada de h porque todo esto es una
función que depende de x y al derivar
respecto de y pues se anula entonces
simplemente tendremos la derivada de h
respecto de g
muy bien ahora que sabemos que la
derivada parcial de epsy respecto de iu
es igual a esta expresión de acá arriba
entonces esto será igual a 2 y m2 muy
bien ahora si queremos averiguar quién
es h
simplemente integramos respecto de yale
a integrales y cuadrada más no perdonó
no más no es menos dos más más una
constante pero si vieron el ejemplo
anterior vamos a ver qué combinaciones
de esta constante con la otra pues nos
vuelve a dar una constante así que vamos
a quedarnos con esta expresión ok
entonces sí que depende de xy de y es
simplemente x cuadrada más 3x y luego
agregamos nuestra función h que en este
caso es de cuadrada menos 2
muy bien ya sabemos que una solución de
la ecuación diferencial original es sí
igual a una constante entonces
simplemente la solución de la ecuación
diferencial es x cuadrada más 3x base
cuadrada menos 2 ye igual a una
constante si tuviéramos condiciones
iniciales adicionales a todo esto
podríamos determinar quiénes se los
animó a tomar la derivada respecto de x
de esta función de forma implícita por
supuesto y que vean que si ustedes
derivan de esa forma entonces lo que
obtienen es esta ecuación diferencial
muy bien
por ahora vamos a hacer otro ejemplo
vamos a borrar toda la imagen y veamos
con mientras más ejemplos veamos pues
mejor verdad así que vamos a tomar este
2x más 4 y
y ahí luego después vamos a sumarle y
hace 12 x menos 2 porque prima igual a
cero ok entonces cuál es la derivada
parcial de esta expresión respecto de y
pues esto simplemente va a ser 4 verdad
porque 2x es constante y la derivada
parcial de esta expresión respecto de x
simplemente va a ser pues 2 la otra
parte pues va a ser cero por lo tanto
estas dos expresiones al derivar las
como lo mencionamos son distintas lo
cual quiere decir que no es exacta ok no
podemos resolverlo utilizando la técnica
que teníamos anteriormente así que vamos
a hacer otra vamos a ver
me estoy quedando sin tiempo voy a hacer
uno que no sea muy complicado digamos 3x
cuadrada menos 2x y ok en realidad
no quiero correr estas cosas mejor vamos
a verlo en el siguiente vídeo nos vemos
luego